foreign
landscape of strategic planning carriers
without Illuminating strategic planner
salary tutorial discover the earning
potential and compensation Dynamics in
this field all in a subtle guide welcome
to Simply learn and today we will learn
the Strategic planners or strategic
Consultants salary details strategic
planners stand as The Architects of
success wielding the blueprints that
guide organizations towards their goals
as companies strive to position
themselves advantageously amidst Fierce
competition and rapid changes the rule
of strategic planner becomes pivotal and
that's what makes the huge salary
packages for strategic planners that
said if these are the type of videos
you'd like to watch then hit that
subscribe button and the bell to get
notified and if you're an aspiring
business analyst looking for online
training and certification from the
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search Norman simply learns postgraduate
program and business analysis from Purge
University in collaboration with Amazon
Google and Microsoft should be your
right choice for more details on this
course use the link in the description
box below also if you're already a
business analyst and want to upgrade
your skills to become a successful data
scientist with proper training and
certifications from the experts and
repeated universities Caltech data
science board Camp should be the right
choice for you for more details use the
link in the description box below so
without further Ado let's get started
with the agenda for today's session
first we will understand what exactly is
strategic planning followed by that we
will learn who is a strategic planner
and the minimum skills required to
become a strategic planner followed by
that we will understand the critical
roles and responsibilities of a strategy
planner in an organization then the
critical part of today's session that is
salaries of a strategic planner followed
by that we will prop up the session by
understanding the company's hiring
strategic planners in the year 2023 and
further now let's proceed with the first
topic what exactly is strategy planning
strategic planning is a process of
defining an organization's long-term
goals and objectives and developing a
plan to achieve them it is a disciplined
effort that produces fundamental
decisions and actions that shape and
guide what an organization is who it is
and who it serves what it does and why
it does it with a focus on the future
now the strategic planning process
typically involves the following steps
Define the organization's vision and
Mission analyze the organization's
external environment analyze the
organizational internal environment set
the organization's goals and objectives
develop a plan to achieve the goals and
objectives implement the plan and
monitor progress evaluate the plan and
make adjustments as needed strategic
planning is an ongoing process that
should be Revisited on a regular basis
by regularly reviewing the
organization's vision mission goals and
objectives the organizations can ensure
that it is on track to achieve the
long-term goals now let's proceed with
the next topic that is who exactly is a
strategy planner
a strategic planner is a professional
who helps organizations develop and
Implement strategic plans they work with
senior leadership to identify the
organization's long-term goals and then
develop a plan to achieve those goals
strategic planners typically have a
background and business economics and
management they also have strong
analytical and problem solving skills
now let's proceed further and understand
the minimum skills required by a
strategic planner here are some of these
skills that are essential for strategic
planners analytical skills problem
solving skills communication skills and
Leadership skills analytical skills
strategic planners need to be able to
gather and analyze information from a
variety of sources second one problem
solving skills strategic planners need
to be able to identify and solve
problems that may impede in the
organizations from achieving its goals
third skill is communication skills
strategic planners need to be able to
communicate effectively with a wide
range of stakeholders including senior
leadership employees customers and
investors and lastly leadership skills
strategic planners need to be able to
lead and motivate others to achieve the
organizational goals so far we have
finished the skills based on the
Strategic planner profile but before we
move further let's hear from our
Learners about their personal experience
and success story after getting
graduated from the business analytics
postgraduate program offered by a simply
learn
hi I'm Cortana vijik I live in Raleigh
North Carolina and working as a business
analyst at levator
this is my second job since I completed
the postgraduate program in business
analytics I simply learned with Purdue
University my experience with simple
learning was great the life classes were
my favorite because they were very
interactive and I could connect with
instructors many small gaps and short
Employments in my career
I even have a huge two-year career Gap
due to some health issues however I
think the dark times are now behind me
it doesn't matter how challenging the
path may be keep up scaling and one day
you will achieve successful feeling
inspired already consider checking the
business analysis postgraduate program
offered by simply loan from Purdue
University in collaboration with IBM for
more details use the link in the
description box below now moving further
we will discuss the roles and
responsibilities of a strategic planner
the specific roles and responsibilities
of a strategy planner can vary depending
on the organization they are working for
however some common tasks include
conducting research and Analysis
developing strategic plans communicating
the Strategic plan monitoring and
evaluating the Strategic plan and lastly
monitoring and evaluating the Strategic
plan now let's discuss each one of these
firstly conducting research and Analysis
strategic planners gather information
about the organization's external
environment such as the competition of
the company and the regulatory landscape
they also analyze the organization's
internal environment such as its
strengths weaknesses and opportunities
second one developing strategic plans
strategic planners use the information
they gather to develop strategic plans
that outline the organization's
long-term goals and how it plans to
achieve them thirdly communicating the
Strategic plan strategic planners
communicate the Strategic plan to the
organization stakeholders such as
employees customers and investors the
last one monitoring and evaluating the
Strategic plan strategic plan is monitor
the organization's progress towards
achieving its goals and make adjustments
to the Strategic plan as and when needed
strategic planners stay as an important
role in helping organizations achieve
their long-term goals by developing and
implementing strategic plans they can
help organizations to stay ahead of the
competition adapters change and Achieve
success now the important part of
today's session that is salary of
strategic planners
a rough estimate of the salary range for
strategic planners in India based on
experience level and the company they
are working for firstly freshers you can
expect anything around 3.5 lakhs per
annum if you're a fresher or a beginner
and if you have an intermediate
experience that is one to two years of
experience then you can expect around 6
lakhs per run and if you're an
experienced candidate that is more than
three years of experience or five years
of experience you can expect a minimum
salary of 10 lakhs per annum now coming
to the USA fresher can expect anything
around fifty thousand dollars annually
and if you're intermediate that is one
to two years of experience you can
expect anything around 75 000 annually
and if you're an experienced candidate
with more than three years or five years
of experience then you can expect around
one lakh dollars per annum and this
might vary because these are just
average numbers and based on the company
and location you're working with you can
expect more now coming into the
company's hiring strategic planners
there are many companies hiring
strategic planners but some of the top
10 companies that are hiring strategic
planners are listed here
those are Accenture Bain and Company
Boston and Consulting Group or BCG
Deloitte ey KPMG leg Consulting McKenzie
and Company Oliver women strategy and
and with this we have reached to the end
of this session on the Strategic planner
salary now should you have any questions
or should you need any assistance PPT or
any other resources used in the session
please do let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be more than happy to help you out
as soon as possible until next time
thank you for watching stay tuned for
more from Simply love staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here